I'm Eddie whoo and this is what keeps me
awake at night children all around the
world are learning to hate one of the
most beautiful and useful sources of
truth mathematics and as they do
humanity may be losing its grip on one
of the keys we need to help us
understand appreciate and save the world
we live in but it doesn't have to be
that way as Barack Obama put it we are
the first generation to feel the effect
of climate change and the last
generation who can do something about it
we need to use logic and mathematics to
help us engineer solutions to solve
global scale problems and move us
forward as a species but that's not the
trajectory we're on right now for
example in New South Wales enrollments
in senior mathematics courses at high
school have dropped to their lowest
numbers in over 50 years while there's
great learning and development happening
in some schools many sectors are still
reporting students who have disengaged
with mathematics some students have so
many gaps in their learning that they
find it all but impossible to recover in
the current system of relentlessly
moving forward at a fixed pace it feels
like something dramatic needs to change
in how we teach and learn mathematics
and that's what keeps me awake at night